In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxarium for July 7th on which we commemorate our righteous father
Thomas of Mount Maleon.
Our holy and venerable father Thomas was of noble and wealthy descent.
Vowed to a military career, he first became famed for his many victories over the barbarians
in the course of the 9th and 10th centuries.
But wounded by the arrows of the love of Christ, he unhesitatingly abandoned the bitter waters
of this life to shoulder the easy and light yoke offered by the Lord to those who desire
to follow him.
And after having received the angelic habit, he strove through voluntary poverty and humility
to imitate our Lord.
Taking the prophet Elias as his model in all things, he was counted worthy to be guided
at night by a pillar of fire along with the holy prophet who led him to Mount Maleon.
He settled there in the strictest isekia, and from then onwards led a life entirely devoted
to prayer.
He shone as a star that through his vigils and prayers illuminated the surrounding country
and banished the darkness of sin and the assaults of the demons.
God added to this the grace of working miracles.
He made a spring gush forth by his prayers, restored sight to the blind and raised up the crippled.
When he stood in prayer, he seemed from afar to be a pillar of fire to those whose purity
of heart had made them worthy of such a sight.
Having wrought many other miracles, this blessed father went to the Lord.
But after his death he never ceased from day to day to deliver from their ills the faithful
who came to venerate his precious relics with faith by means of a miraculous balm that
flowed from his tomb.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.